today me and all these boys are playing
3d among
us we have dream jacksepticeye george
sapnet wildcat carl
chandler me the everyone even laser beam
i'm dumb
this is very cool we can all move around
in 3d we can all agree that we hate
dream who's ready
ready let's get it i don't agree all
right ready up then
[Music]
no way i got it all right i'm imposter
again wait where am i going
imposter again i don't i don't like that
i just want to let you know that this
game is not available publicly this
right here danny is the creator of 3d
among us
go to his channel it'll be linked in
description subscribe
i want to be imposter man i'm following
sean
oh now the lights are off i'm having so
much fun
i i want to be the imposter
[Music]
what what dead bodies are so funny in
this
i want to be impostor i want to see what
it's like oh
the doors just closed like right behind
me doing these tasks but i'm faking
doing it i'm destroying asteroids oh
there's a lava pit
all right let's not walk in that all
right i'm just going to follow dream
around carol
what are you doing that was so creepy i
don't like this
i i think mr beast is evil oh god get
away from me
get away from me get away from me no i
don't know what's
going on here okay chandler just blocked
my path
what was that wait i just saw blood
splatter on my screen
wait was it right outside uh med bay
yeah yeah i thought i saw that i think
it's dream you want to hear my story
i want to hear your story because it
needs to be good i thought mr beast was
going to kill me so i've been spamming
report the last like 45 seconds i was
behind someone who didn't know i was
behind them i'm pretty sure it was danny
i thought you were going to kill me so i
was
running this is like the world's first
ever 3d stack kill this is crazy
i vote dream yeah i kind of do believe
he is spamming report dream let me
where's the body
he said he doesn't know but i was
walking through the lab i think i'm suss
of george
it's either danny or george that is
definitely george no no it's not me 100
is not me wait who did people vote for
people already voted
well yes why would you dream
nobody felt voted wait why
i think because not enough people voted
and two people troll voted dream it
threw dream out i don't think we
actually wanted to throw a dream out
uh should we call emergency meeting
should we get george out of here
wait who voted who voted dream i didn't
vote there was only three people that
voted that nap drew voted for dream step
why'd you vote dream
i thought it was dream but it was it i
think it's jimmy vote him out
our jack the fact that you keep doing
that is sucks we can't like dream dine
vain though i mean we gotta vote george
right no no stop stop stop don't
wait is that danny saying that that is
me saying that yeah uh
yeah you would say that it's wild
captain george no it is not me
it's not me all right i'm not a george i
no don't vote me i already voted you
george i'm a trust dream here
no who do we vote george wild cat it's
wildcat it's one
george it's danny it's definitely danny
it's literally not me you guys are so
wrong i skipped dude they're gonna think
it's me i'm third imposter
honestly i really think it's zap nap is
mysteries gonna kill me
oh wildcat what is going on
what is going on wait what how's
chandler up there
oh my god you can climb the rock what
step get away from me
zap nap wait that's only one more dead
zapnap wouldn't leave me alone you
wouldn't leave me alone was the real
thing
i think it's danny sapnap i can confirm
though it's not steph zapp was following
me around it's a wildcat
oh it's danny danny pushed both of those
kills i walk yeah you're pushing me now
really i wanted to skip i didn't think
it was dream
me and you were together sap and
chandler just left us i don't think
chandler killed someone at that time it
is either danny or wildcat
it's both telling you it's danny it is
absolutely not me danny pushed both
those votes okay if i was imposter i
would not push that hard
let's do danny and if it's not danny we
do no no no no no do vodka
first it's on boys oh let's see it where
are we right
oh um jimmy no bro
hey guys you guys call it emergency
meeting dream
this is your fault i need to call an
emergency meeting wait how many
how many are there run run oh run
run run oh wait there's the wave
was chandler and the wildcat i get i
guess i'm third imposter now
i actually have a positive story let's
do it all right i'm imposter oh my god
it's me and mr beast
nobody kill me leave me alone leave me
alone i'm just a lonely little guy just
doing my thing
is it mr beast is it jimmy the lights
let's go lights
murdered on the lights panel dude come
on look at me dude
oh no lazy just saw me oh wow why did i
see cyan running away from lights
really oh my goodness i know who did it
so that's cool
i was with danny yeah i know i saw
george running away from lights he
literally headbutted me as he was
leaving
i was just running to go do tasks oh
you're running i do taste say george
okay
you're always rushing to vote me out so
quick no i actually saw george do this
kill no no
what do you mean he okay what do you
mean you saw me i was nowhere near
the the body was on lots that's fine i
already voted george you don't have to
tell me twice no yeah we're voting with
george
it's laser it's laser bye oh
that's payback george hey wait wait look
who skipped who skipped who was the one
that skipped that means they're imposter
i'm sorry mr beast i'm sorry the one
time he got it i messed it up him i'm so
sorry could you have done any worse
george oh he's gonna go into the toilets
right i think so yeah
dude i found this last round i'm not
even kidding is someone gonna stack kill
now that'd be bad
oh i gotta kill jack get away
oh well i got the engine on anyway oh my
dead body
i feel bad for george the only reason i
knew it was him was a headbutter i i'm
not going to get mr beast voted out
because i know he's had a tough time
well as it was so i was with dream
sapping carl so
neither of us could have done the kill
i'm with laser right now yeah well it
wasn't based
uh no i think danny is full of honk
right now whoa
wait why danny did leave yeah where's
the body oh it wasn't the body i just
went to the button
who was the one who skipped last round
though uh maybe george
i think i saw yellow but i cannot
confirm that's enough for me
no no no no no no no no no i can't
confirm i don't know
that's enough for me danny he kind of
confirmed him bloody's on your shoulders
dude yeah i know he's thought out
accusations and trying to find what
sticks
no i didn't that was an accusation it's
danny i was i was in the stalls
he still got the blood on him was it him
oh snap oh no oh
dream step back to the spot is it beast
is it jimmy
i i think it's mr beast but i am just
gonna vouch for him i'm gonna be a mr
bass simp
oh my god come on you can't do this you
can't stack like this
what is this like what am i supposed to
do
i'm just waiting to see a kill happen
like from the sky right here i'm gonna
be just perched up on this rock
i don't know you could climb rocks dude
what's up chandler hey big dog
hey what's up buddy
they're all stacking somewhere it's
pretty dweeby
so i'm assuming everyone's stacking
somewhere no no why are you looking for
a kill i think it'd just make it really
hard for anyone who actually is imposter
though so it made me think
that jimmy what did i do last game i did
like 30 tasks and that's what i was
doing at the start of this game
base couldn't have done the last one did
we get one of the bad guys out yet
we did and by the way i was the one of
the first ones to throw them under the
bus and i got george out so it's either
the kill cooldown is so quick at the
start of the game though and it could
have been someone before they went to
your hiding spot well here's the thing
we know there's only one left we have 10
seconds and it ha
and we're voting carl all right you know
you know that really does make sense to
me
we skip here we skip here what is this
game
what do i do i'm skipping see listen did
you hear that did you hear that carl i
could have killed you there carl you
think i'm freaking imposter
is it jimmy i don't know if that was the
right move or not i could have thrown
carl under the bus i didn't
i want to go find this hidden spot is it
laser beam i feel like it might be
carl's really sucks at me so i have to
kill carl
oh my god that's it i can't do anything
while they're stacked like this
beast kill one of them what's happening
kill one of them don't just don't kill
me kill them kill him
all right yeah but laser is one of the
few people that trust me no don't kill
me don't kill me don't kill me
no i can't kill him he's my only alibi
right now like i'll
hard clear you dude i've got you i'm
with you later i'm with you don't worry
buddy
you could murder in front of me and i
would say it wasn't you
hey get away ladies
oh it's over i must protect him
okay it's jimmy how do you unmute so
fast no i just watched carl kill him nah
it's call it's actually call
no i guarantee guys i guarantee i was
with beast
all game dude nah it's call yeah come on
coral wait jimmy don't say it
where is he right now then where is he
right now he's in electrical okay maybe
you saw him i swear to god
this is why carl the entire last round
was trying to build something
get kyle out of here hey if you guys
want to give jimmy a compelling video
where he absolutely outplays everybody
then vote for me
nah mate get out of here call you always
do this girl
chandler chandler chandler chandler
please please vote jimmy here wait we're
not just gonna let whoever talks the
loudest
nah listen listen i was with bass please
vote jimmy here if it isn't jimmy it is
me
i literally have laser here vouching for
me i was with bass the whole time if it
isn't jimmy
it is me if it isn't carl it's me i
literally have laser here vouching for
me who here is vouching for carl no one
i was
i was with i was with him the whole time
all right it's carl i told you
oh my god uh beast i was trying so hard
dude i was trying so hard
wow george threw it for him basically i
hope you enjoyed this game of dream carl
and sapnap staying together
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you haven't already hit that
subscribe button i'm trying to be
dreamed of 20 million subscribers that
is all that matters go subscribe i'll
see you in the next video